I'm no movie critic but I feel pretty
right meow Amy Schumer's I feel pretty
and super troopers 2 is in theaters this
weekend this is your weekend ticket this
week's top ticket is Amy Schumer's I
feel pretty this movie should be a
headliner in your weekend itinerary if
you're a fan of Freaky Friday or big or
any switcharoo movies support strong
female driven comedies or if you find
yourself lol at any of a me Schumer's
previous films like train wreck or
snatched I feel pretty as a modern take
on the old switcharoo story that finds
Amy Schumer's character Renee suddenly
struck with a newfound streak of
self-confidence the edgy Schumer has
tone mixed with an important message
about body shaming and cultural Beauty
pressures make for an empowering comedy
about self-love and acceptance and it's
not just Amy Schumer the notable cast
also features 80 Bryant's Busy Philipps
and Michelle Williams the boys a broken
lizard have returned with their long
awaited and aptly named sequel to Super
Troopers Super Troopers 2 why did it
take so long for the sequel to get made
well I had to wait for it Kevin girls
mustache this mustache here took many
many years to get 15 years to grow this
mustache we also needed to wait until
420 fill in a Friday and that happens
only every 20 years
yeah this movie is definitely for you
this weekend if you're a fan of modern
slapstick comedies you love any of the
other films from the Broken Lizard
comedy troop like club dread or Beer
Fest are you just looking to kick back
and get a good laugh in Super Troopers 2
maintains the expected level of
inappropriate humor and antics from the
first film Mack thorny Foster rabbit and
Farva all returned to their
unconventional police work as they're
called into action to Throwdown in an
international border dispute between the
US and Canada
they've come up here to tell us how
great it's gonna be for all of us to
become Americans the original super
troopers film built such a huge cult
following that it made 18 million
dollars domestic and 13 years later it
inspired a 4.6 million dollar campaign
which at the time of funding was the
second-highest crowdfunded movie reboot
next to Veronica Mars with 5.7 and that
is your weekend ticket and make sure to
check back next week as Marvel
Universe's collide and Avengers infinity
war and hey while we're here why not
leave a comment and tell us what's your
favorite strong female driven comedy
that makes you feel pretty
[Music]